and I like the chuckwagon it talks about
speciation I'm not telling you what he
told me 30 years ago so Charlie is a
professor of population genetic using
days yeah so I received this assignment
which is ironic in the sense that I
while I've had a number of postdocs in
my lab who worked diligently and I'll
talk about some of their work on
speciation night I you won't find my
fingerprints on speciation except for
the work I did as an undergraduate and
but but I I am a student of speciation
in an interested in it and actually this
assignment has changed my attitude about
not so much about speciation but the
context of speciation in a more positive
way as you'll see well probably after
lunch anyway so it's sort of hard to
know exactly what to present in this
setting of this of this program but I've
decided to take a pretty simple
straightforward approach and make sure
that everybody sort of on a little bit
on the same page and there's some basic
things and then devote maybe a latter
half to sort of more recent exciting
things so the beginning of our this is I
put this up just as to start because
this is going to be an essential part of
the of the idea this is a quote from
meijer but actually probably more
championed by Deb Cheyenne ski and let
me see my poor computers here's Joe the
ubs be got pulled out there there we go
so and I have one more disclaimer of
right in about 10 minutes or 15 minutes
you could go over to vlsb and see
Michael turelli speak I don't think he's
going to talk about speciation he
probably talking about his recent work
on will ba kia but he's one of the
greatest living students of speciation
and contributed much to both theoretical
and many of the interesting meta
analyses and he also just to make sure I
didn't get too far off the path and
since he had in recent last few years
delivered lectures on speciation two
groups not unlike this one he shared
with me some of his notes some of it was
useful some of it was arcane and so I
but I want to admit that I've
plagiarized or worse than plagiarizing
plagiarized is his stuff some of his
stuff okay so this is the basic topics
that I want to cover I'll discuss this
basic concept in the context it's very
much related to the ideas that Monty
introduced yesterday from the history of
the neo-darwinian synthesis and then
really in some sense reversing
directions a little bit but to get into
the biogeography of speciation which
predated well Darwin was a practitioner
and many others had ideas about how
diversity arose related to biogeography
we'll do a little bit with time scale
and I'll show you some of the crude
tools that much progress has been made
with them but I think we can expect a
much better more accurate view of the
process that will describe we'll look at
in the coming decade is as much of the
ancient simple gene-based data is
replaced with genomic data of course
fundamental to to the concept of
reproductive isolation is of course the
genetic basis is a post you will deal
with postzygotic isolation which have to
do with genetic incompatibilities I will
spend some time and this is sort of my
rheostat on the whole discussion this
woodbridge over into lunch there's a
there's a wealth of
and genetic analysis of actual cases
individual cases the believe it or not
there have not there only a handful
still that are quite interesting and
illuminating in and I think it's
important with respect to what i want to
say at the end for me to dwell on it
just for you to get some sense of how
hard these people have worked for a
decade and a half to just get one gene
and you know seven students in three
postdocs in three nih grants and one
gene so it's a lot of work and and i
think we're ready both after that
experience and also technologically to
start to to consider more genome-wide
and higher throughput approach how to
mail that with the biology that
underlies this will be a challenge of
course okay so let's start here with
with the basic idea so Darwin and
everybody else who thought about this
seriously in the last century realized
that in the system attest before that
linnea them realized that organisms
tended to be clustered individually into
groups which were species and then as
the as genetics started in view the
concepts of organismic biology and
Darwin introduced the concept of actual
processes going on in populations it was
quite natural to develop an idea about a
species that was based on separate
lineages and that they they are distinct
lineages and in order for them to be
distinct there has to be some mechanism
which prevents makes them reproductively
isolated so populations of organisms
that have become in some sense
reproductively separated now before I
get into the details a little bit more
detail about this let me just point out
two really important aspects of
speciation and in this whole topic one
is of course that if you do biology it's
critical that you actually
have what you think you have and
actually geneticist population
geneticists are much closer to say
computer scientists when it comes to
actually figuring out what material to
use and so forth there are people who
small number usually one or two for each
group of organisms who have really
devoted a large part of their life to
keeping track of what's out there and
what what's there and so there are
practical reasons to cluster things even
if you don't have the the detailed
genetics or whatever to actually be sure
about every every case and so when you
start to do biology you need somebody to
tell you what species you're working
with and so it has enormous practical
applications independent of these more
high-level concepts historically and
still today when there's ambiguity today
and historically what's a separate
species is a matter of authority very
often and at least the way it appears in
the literature I mean for example if you
if you have data that shows that two
populations are not are reproductively
not isolated you could write a paper
where you say I think these are
different species but if you don't go
through the formalism of systematics to
declare these now new species the
journals and the whole journal
Biological editorial process will sort
of cough and resist you so there's a
whole process of that has to do with the
formalism of naming and most of us don't
have time for this at all so we'd rely
on people who actually have chosen that
is their occupation and so there's this
delicate relationship between the
practical and authority that one has to
keep in mind so I raised this only if
you find yourself in in these days more
and more in genomics people are working
on new organisms that haven't been
studied very well before and it's a
common experience of evolutionary
biologists to be handed a group of
organisms and start doing some analysis
and discover oh yeah these two are not
really different species
or this one is actually two different
species it comes out of the genetics
pretty cool population genetics pretty
quickly so dealing with these practical
things is sort of a part of the of the
process okay so the basic idea that came
out of the knee or emerged during the
neo-darwinian these synthesis and that
like in there in the 40s 30s and 40s
dart and of chancy as I said was a
champion admired also was to say let's
don't depend on authority let's don't
depend on morphology let's have an
operational and not only an operational
definition in terms of actual genet
maybe you can do genetic analysis to see
if they're reproductively isolated to
populations but more importantly that
the reproductive isolation is the
necessary and sufficient condition for
it was assumed and it seems to be true
is holding up is that if two populations
are reproductively isolated long enough
they will diverge and never come back
together now modern gene techni
technology can probably overcome
everything but in the real world that's
a half that's the way it happens now one
of the things that's right each
introductory evolutions so forth I
always make an enormous apology as we
just heard most of life on Earth most
life today by biomass most everything
about life is in fact largely
prokaryotic and certainly microbial and
so this definition here because of their
the reproductive life history of
microbes that this this is a much too
stringent requirement to define a
species for microbes because the
assumption of being reproductively
isolated to groups is that they actually
there's some kind of necessary
reproductive interaction of individuals
so outbreeding multicellular organisms
uomo eukaryotes
they of course can fit fine into that if
they're obligate out breeders or fairly
common out breeders but for example some
of you I know of wrestled with the the
population genetics genomics of say just
simple yeast isolates or other fungi
it's quite complicated to think about
what the individual is and with respect
to our models that we've been discussing
or we'll discuss where is the individual
where how often do they actually
reproduce in what way so this concept
becomes fails and I think it's generally
accepted that that the microbial world
relies much more on on on these two
necessary conditions for dealing with
what is in fact I mean there is
coherence to lots of microbial organisms
in nature but the coherence is not based
on this and there could be lots of small
side shoots wandering off in different
directions we would be hard-pressed to
know that okay so the final thing is by
way of introduction I just want to warn
you if you if you end up spending
decades in biology you will live long
enough to have to sit through one or
more occasions where somebody is
insisting on having a better idea about
what a species concept is than the
biological species concept in and I hope
that happens some day but you know most
of the time these things serve some
secondary on the ecological or maybe
some particular group of organisms in
some practical way but actually don't
carry over to evolution very well at all
so I want to say one more thing before I
get started I I be I would have a much
better time and you would have a much
better time if I if I say anything you
don't understand and I really don't have
a good gauge of your the biology here so
on I'm probably if there's things that
people want to talk about some of these
things please do okay so here's the
basic thing now to God giving it to
where i'm going to go much of what's
happened in the last 15 or 20 years is
very careful re-examination of the
patterns of isolation that occur in
nature among different groups especially
sister tax or closely related species of
animals and plants and the great much as
you will see the great majority is
always give a very clear story that was
noted by early investigators Jordan and
even even Darwin to some extent noted
that closely related organisms very
often are found not superimposed
geographically but isolated separated
and the other one of the difficult
problems with trying to determine in
natural environments what's whether
things are reproductively isolated to
different is it there are a multitude of
ecological and behavioral sources of
potential sources of bear of isolation
that one has to always be aware of okay
so those are sort of caveats so the
basic set of bread and butter of
speciation biology his first besides the
biological species concept is to divide
the isolation mechanisms into pre and
post zygotic so already we're thinking
about dip lloyds and as i said that for
this this idea to go down the road in
any effective way we you basically need
it to be a sort of almost out breeding
population and so then when there
there's mating there can be isolation
that occurs before may
or after mating and sometimes these some
people for a while there was confusion i
think that literature is pretty much
settled now on pre and post I gotik but
there used to be a distinction some
people were pre and post mating some
people were pre and post zygotic but
these days mostly people talk pre and
post zygotic but there couldn't be
mechanisms obviously these are mating
mechanisms and other ecological
mechanisms that could prevent I so
create isolation by pregnate in
isolation okay so yeah Oh for example a
lot of lot of animals basically just
don't recognize even close especially
we'll get to in a minute but for example
in those cases where the close relative
actually does live in the same
geographic area it's very common for
them to recognize right away that that's
not the right species and behaviorally
in their nerve I got it that would be
presiding pose I got it would be failure
to develop or failure failure for the
fertilization to even occur or to
develop in what looks like a perfectly
normal organism except can't find its
way home right or goes into the wrong
niche or serum or sterile is of course
the most common single phenotype for
ones that are viable yeah
because they don't like you or they
cannot produce offspring we'll get to
that in a minute the answer is yes okay
so here's a really good example one
that's newer there's a lot of these are
examples excuse me there are examples of
ones were of pre psychotic isolation is
sometimes systematically different among
organisms this is a fairly for a long
time we resisted this idea that there
might be some sort of biological
differences between groups of organisms
in the in the whole process but it's
become quite clear very elegant work of
this kind of meta-analysis of lots of
different species pairs that the
songbirds by and large have remarkable
amount of tolerance of mating if you can
get them to mate they produce viable
offspring quite nicely and they do
they're fertile but the most of the
songbird pairs their close relatives
they they very have very strong
cremating isolation and that's
presumably involved with the mate choice
mate you know the behavioural complex
that goes around those organisms may
drive that process just make it much
more efficient at recognizing potential
problems in drosophila as account as an
old and we'll see if the counter exam a
be more representative example that rate
at which these things appear as you'll
see in a minute is pretty much the same
about the same rate oh sorry I'm I'm
going to get to that in just like that
shouldn't be there but anyway allopatric
means is geographically distinct so or
just to get ahead of myself just one
slide allopatric means two different
places in a geographic sense there could
be different they could be sympatric lee
they could be geographically in the same
county or even in the same tree but
somehow within the trees separated and
that that does happen rarely but
allopatric refers to
just the range distribution in geography
and so if they're allopatric they're in
different places yeah so then I was
going to get to that next so in there
are you can imagine that there's
isolation that arises because of the
inherent biology usually intrinsic means
you it happens in the lab okay and
extrinsic are usually things that are
contingent on something in nature or not
it not only contingent sometimes it
nature's doing it period right okay now
here's yeah sorry Emile yes that's true
that's true but the horses that the
horses that produce mules would have
fewer horse horse offspring because
they're making mules and those meals are
not having any progeny and so those
horses are not as fit as the ones that
choose to mate with other horses so our
bill was just because of our visual
oh there are many situations in which
hybrids actually have certain kinds of
bigger mules are very strong useful
organisms in some settings they just
don't reproduce whatcha thinkin of it is
that our new music occur naturally or
are they like I don't think they occur
naturally no really don't know as far as
I know what they are yeah you know no
they wouldn't I ya know but if you put a
horse and a donkey in that pin for a
week or something that something will
happen ok I I don't know the details of
the horse don't see hybrid zones oh no
the mule in the mule case we see like
we'll get to that in a minute there are
plenty of hybrids in nature it's just
that particular one I don't know about
it being in nature but there are plenty
of hybrids in nature will spend quite a
bit of time in the next lecture talking
about ok ok so so there these are
observations that that I think are
probably important in this kind of
setting to realize is that that the
variation that one sees between closely
related species when you measure
everything at the morphological
physiological level there's no sort of
unique difference that species have that
doesn't occur within the species also so
the same kind of variation may be the
magnitude is not always quite as great
but there doesn't seem to be a
qualitative difference in this is quite
a I think are quite widely accepted in
general result there's doesn't seem to
be at the level the macroscopic level
certainly will get to the genomic issues
in a minute but anyway so that's
important and so the conclusion that
most people draw from this is that that
it's not there's not some special
process that's going on but that
speciation is really the
at least it's yeah it may be sufficient
and it's certainly a good starting
position to just assume that natural
selection and other processes are going
on within a population if those two
populations are separated the cumulative
effects of that will not only be as we
heard adaptation to local environments
but they will also lead to
incompatibilities such that the hybrids
are less fit and that whole process its
associated with the hybrids being less
fit is really what we we want to
concentrate on and so it's this is what
I was just saying is it is thought that
that in especially in a love hatchery
the divergence that occurs just due to
other processes would be enough to Lee
or could lead to this divergence is the
basis of the incompatibility and I i
said i'll mention it another slide you
can see it in the slides I this first
part of this talk is not only crib from
Torelli but it's basically an synopsis
not a very good one I would say of the
book that I was showing you on the front
page a few years ago Jerry Coyne in
Eleanor wrote a a sort of definitive
book on speciation and all the
references or anyway this reference and
a number of other references I mean it
can be found in that book and this is a
famous paper now from 20 years old that
use the Isthmus of Panama to study the
and this would be pre mating isolation
of different kinds of crabs where
there's a there was originally one
population when the ocean covered the
Isthmus and as the ocean got lower and
lower the I the crabs species then
became separated and so they're pairs of
species on each side of the of the of
the Isthmus and knowlton and her
colleagues did a simple thing they had
this particular crab had a really easy a
se for mating acceptance and so they
just took crabs from me
side of the Isthmus and presented them
to the crabs on the other side and made
and develop some kind of score for
whether they would accept the crabs and
it showed a very nice cumulative effect
of time the crabs that have been
separated very recently are more
interested in the crabs from the other
side of the Isthmus than the ones that
have been separated for five million
years and there's a sort of linear
relationship between the ability the pre
mating isolation measures a pre-meeting
isolation and and the time that they've
been separated so that that's just a one
of the sort of classic cases or I'll
show you some more in a minute under
sopla but that one is very simple to
understand and it has a nice geological
dating paired sample kind of design
which is nice congestion mechanism for
how this happens nice is correlation
between people are going to trial but
really maybe isolation yeah so that you
get so how it happens I guess I guess
what we could the answer is almost no
okay but everybody is quite comfortable
with the idea that there is natural
selection going on all the time and and
as you if you think about a little bit
about hybrid and compatibility we'll get
to in a minute that's a that has to be
an interac an egg ative interaction
between genes that have or yeah genes
that have evolved on one lineage and
genes involved on the other you bring
them together they have a negative
interaction and in so the question is
what are those jeans that are diverging
you know in some sense it's a whole
genome but different rates and so forth
and to what extent are they how what are
the mechanisms and the frequency of the
incompatible interactions but this also
has to come with some sort of cognitive
these crabs a cognitively evolving to
prefer you know if it has initially were
all well they prefer their just evolving
to mate with the ones that are in their
neighborhood right and over a million
years they get pretty they keep up with
that then they're all mating very
happily here comes a strange-looking
crab from the other side of this with
you know I'm not that interested right
let's close as the species diverged then
cognitively they also need a diversion
their mating preferences which is kind
of interesting yeah and in fact most
evolutionists think that almost all
characters are diverging may there may
be in a directional way sometimes
sometimes in a in a random way but they
don't the berry you know their stasis is
there in a gross scale but a lot of
there's a lot going on under the hood I
mean after all you know the genes are
turning over at a pretty hefty radio
shows I've got no problem and it is I
mean that's a computer scientist have
and this is graph okay but but but the
fact that cognitively their preferences
track is random divergence that you know
our ancestors all used to be but
cognitively they're probably tracking
their population which is moving in some
direction and so after a period of time
that the two populations are did look
different you can look at them they look
different and they can tell the
difference in overtime they look more
and more different yeah I think that's
what everybody thinks is going on I
don't think it's you know I don't think
we know anything d and this the crabs
are not a model system listen this was
like a lot of sunshine and walk scuba
diving and there wasn't much genomics
involved because the other way the
evolution of their preferences could
drive the character development ugly
like sexual selection for sure I mean
presumably the crabs part of the mate
choice and the crabs is involved with
these characters that they display to
each other and so there's sexual
selection going on you know in almost
all operating organisms are strong
sexual selection going on and that's
constantly a competitive frequency
dependent process so sometimes p to the
individuals q on new character so that
will drive a new character
and then pretty soon the populations got
fancy clothes or is lost or whatever so
we don't really but it's generally
thought that not only these mating
characters but disease resistance
competition and environment to the
physical adaptation the physical
environment is driving some rate of
substitution and that the genes are at
this point where you have to consider
that all of those genes could be
involved in the incompatibility the
divergences in those jeans okay so this
isn't I hope I never have to do this
again I guess I will have to do it in
the fall when I teach hot russian so so
unfortunately because when you're
studying speciation you want lots of
different species pairs because the only
data point you have is a pair of species
that are closely related and so that
means you have to collect data on first
the phenotype for example we were
looking at crabs we'd have to look at
whether they want to mate or behave
hostility towards each other in the case
of drosophila postzygotic you would have
to make matings and see if the embryos
survived a lot of work goes into the
type the phenotyping and
characterization of the biology and
almost all these organisms are esoteric
hard to get and interesting to work with
but they don't have very good genetics
or population genetics heaven in the
past and so as Monte mentioned yesterday
they but they are very ripe for the
classic sort of allozyme technology so
almost everything we know about the
rates of divergence at the genetic level
with respect to hybridization and
speciation and is based on allozyme data
and so it's a little bit I like I said I
hope we don't stay here very much longer
because I'm not so worried about the
quality of the data but the number of
low sigh and the resolution of the date
it's very noisy compared to what we can
do now we have the whole genome we get
we don't even we can nail the divergence
tubes you know several significant
digits so it's a very different world so
but this is a classic neighs genetic
distance it just measures this is just
the proportion of identity when alleles
chosen from
different groups to different
populations compared to the identity
when it's when it in the in the two
alleles chosen from the same population
and with the usual sort of correction
for mutation plots on nature of
mutations you can get a good
approximation that should be an
approximate size sorry for the
divergence between the two populations
and so this is like a standard tool
al-azhar's in this tool can give you
some measure of how different two
populations are at the genetic level in
the genome the genes presumably don't
have anything to do with incompatibility
and they're very few they're usually the
same set of 20 to 30 genes chosen
because they're convenient and but we're
going to use this measure to get a
handle on the rate and properties of
incompatibility and I just sort of get
warmed up here a little bit with the
vagaries of this I want to I'll spend a
moment here just going over a little bit
of typical data so this is this is just
some data for subpopulation so this
would be things that everybody agrees
are the same species even the same
subspecies there's no taxonomic dispute
what's other just different places in
the distribution of the organism and so
people this is data from Conan or this
is collected a different resolution are
different numbers of populations for all
these different species such humans and
mice this is the horseshoe crab and the
Anolis lizards and fish in drosophila
and you can see they're just not very
many low site involved in these
estimates and that these are the sort of
range of observations for the divergence
very little divergence actually between
most of these animals because they get
around pretty well and populations are
not very different if you go to what the
authorities refer to as subspecies and
of course the subspecies is sort of like
a hot potato in the sense that it a
subspecies could become a species if you
did some more work and you show that was
really reproductively isolated
or it could just be Geographic
differentiation and it's not really a
thing it's just two ends of a continuum
and so most most geneticists and
population geneticists really handle
subspecies gingerly they don't usually
suspiciously just like it's just a
species just another population it might
be a little bit different shape but the
point is that what I recognize that the
systemic level as subspecies often do
have considerably more divergence
between populations then do things that
are not subspecies so after all the
system assists are detecting populations
that are differentiated whether they are
reproductively have any reproductive
isolation or not is usually the people
who do reproductive isolation usually
would just ignore this and say well okay
there's just some more populations and
then if they were reproductively
isolated they declare them at different
species okay now here's the critical
data but like I said I'm not terribly
happy with the numbers but the results
seem to hold up so we feel pretty
comfortable about them so this is a
number again of animal species and and
what we're looking at is sibling closely
related species usually sister taxa and
asking how diverged are are they sister
taxa that are in fact the closest good
species now at this point I'm using my
authority to tell you what good species
is but suffice it to say most of these
would pass the past the biological
species concept and so it's roughly that
the regime is I mean days d is about
point O a twitch when calibrated from
fossil record for different organisms
and differently for some of these but
it's roughly a million years so I
usually keep as a sort of rule of thumb
try to imbue it on other people as I'm
not sure if it's it could be off by an
order by factor two or so but roughly
for animals and I think probably for
plants it might be a
bit different we don't really have a
good enough data I don't think looks
like it's about a million years there's
a sort of mosa nominal time for for
things to be evolved into what's
considered a good species okay now I
want to go back to this question that we
discuss a little bit before and just go
over this again so pre mating and post
mating isolation is thought to I mean
first of all isolation is thought to
almost all of it like eighty ninety
percent of the cases where you have
populations that have evolved biological
isolation reproductive isolation usually
these have occurred in Halep a tree and
the evidence for that is first of all as
I mentioned in the beginning a lot of
organisms they they are found to not
co-occur even though their sister taxa
so they'll be on two different sides of
a mountain range or two different sides
of a river and and they but they're the
closest relatives and so they're in ala
pantry and it's assumed and sometimes
demonstrated that they that they have
been that way for quite a while and that
the reproductive isolation arose in
that's in that situation that as we just
discussed that the actual isolation
could arise because of selection for any
number of traits which then could give
rise in hybrids to some kind of
incompatibility and as I mentioned
Darwin and Jordan and Jordan was really
an early champion of this idea that when
you find the closest relative species
it's almost always geographically
separated there is controversy about
this because there are some wonderful
cases of sympatric speciation that have
definitely been nailed down and I didn't
want to present it because I find
meta-analysis pretty dull but actually
there's a bunch of heavy lifting of
meta-analysis of all the cases of all
the different organisms and trail has
been involved a little bit in this
anyway it's it's it's holding up the
almost all of these contentions about
allopatric and so forth have
have listed fairly i would say complete
meta-analysis of a available data on a
number of different groups of organisms
so now this gets me now to the to the
nub of the ana turning point here I
think I I want to say just before we
leave is that sympatric speciation is
people will say maybe one or two percent
maybe five percent of the cases where
species arise in sympatric almost always
involve some some unique property of the
ecology and the behavior for example the
classic one that's often cited is an
insect that grows on say a native a wild
fruit say wild cherry and then the
farmers plant a whole bunch of cherry
trees in michigan and the insect one of
the insects are a couple of insects for
whatever reason start jump onto the
cherry and since the organisms mate and
live on the fruit is the ones that tend
to go to this new fruit are have a
propensity to stay on that fruit and so
very quickly you get a second population
that's totally geared towards the second
the new introduced resource and so there
is a strong coupling between mating and
resources in almost all the cases in
animals where you see sympatric
speciation that's pretty valid there's
almost always a very strong coupling
between mating and resource ecological
resource the other one that recently has
come out as there's these African nest
parasite Birds they're quite it's a
whole group of them they're very clever
they basically lay their eggs in the
nests of other birds and the chicks then
grow up hearing the song of the new
species and so they and then in the
male's sing it and pretty soon they just
adopted and they have a new clay that's
now parasitizing this other one and they
learned the song from the other one and
the daughters who grew up in those nests
heard the song from there
father and so they just become nest
parasites of the next species and they
don't interbreed with the ones that were
on the other species because they have a
different song so forth so it happens
very quickly and and so these organisms
have these birds have radiated quite
extensively in very rapidly and often
sympatric Lee simple definition Patrick
yeah this is overlapping geographic
distribution okay sorry what a long time
before sympatric yeah I mean if you have
amazing difference time bonus I'm going
to get to that in a minute ya ever get
to the plot that your software data
where that's solid okay anyway so we
want to know something more about this
process and but before we do that I want
to I want to mention the more
complicated cases besides symmetry and a
la patrie which are quite interesting
and one of the things that happens more
than we ever wanted to know but now we
we know was theta becomes better data on
more organisms become clearer and we
listen to our geologists more carefully
we realized that that there's a lot of
potential secondary contact so what
happens is in organisms are physically
in our pantry they diverge but sometimes
they come back together and have
secondary contact it's called and the
populations start to interact and they
form hybrids in a hybrid zone conform at
these boundaries where they come back
together and for example you can have a
whole summer of tourism in Europe
studying hybrid zones that have to do
with the glaciation moving back and
forth everything from bears to
grasshoppers and all kinds of plants
there are hybrid zones and almost all
the alpine and Pyrenees pass you just
walk over the Panthers one species here
one there and there's a hybrid zone in
the mountain pass and these are all
secondary contacts and and when you have
a secondary contact there they're
basically are as there's sort of two
scenarios or three depending on what
how fun that you want to divide it up
obviously if they've evolved pre mating
isolation already then they're going to
just become good species because there
won't be any way for them they'll be
isolated permanently so if they don't
recognize each other and don't mate in
the field they'll be separate on the
other hand if they do make and they but
they're sterile or enviable they'll be
good species but of course both sexes
and both sexes have to be sterile and/or
enviable if one sex is sams to be viable
and fertile then there can be back
crossing with the other species and
genes could flow between the two
populations so these are what leads to
good species and then there there's an
interesting alternative is let's suppose
that the hybrids are fertile and
enviable obviously the thing could just
fuse back into one species how long it
would take it would obviously set up a
hybrid zone depending on how much
differentiation there's been but they
would the in principle on some time
scale having to do with the rate of
migration and so forth the populations
could just fuse back into one big
population on the other hand if the
hybrids are less fit then either parent
especially in the hybrid zone then what
you will get is a hybrid zone forming
where we're in hybrids are being formed
and genes may be flowing slowly
depending on their phenotypic effect and
this is a very interesting and I think
now wide open area with modern genomics
to try to identify what genes are moving
across these hybrid barriers which ones
are moving fast across which ones are
being inhibited and do they interact
it's a really sort of natural experiment
that doesn't need a lot of resources
because you really have two end points
that are pretty well defined and a
fairly narrow object to study so this is
in I just did a little scan last night
in the letter
it's just everybody who can get you know
$20,000 together and buy some time on a
little machine is trying to do some
study of a hybrid zone or Klein or some
species pairs literature sort of and
people are I'll talk about the analysis
in a little in a minute okay so that
that's that's important so so this leads
to that the most interesting from my my
experience in studying I went in when I
was a graduate student this was a good
topic if you wanted to you know if you
were an evolutionist to study was try to
find ways to find evidence in this
situation that pre mating isolation
actually evolves in response to a hybrid
zone or a hybrid interaction hybrid
swarm if they just come together as one
population in which the hybrids are less
fit then any gene that makes an
individual not mate with its with the
other species will have a higher fitness
because more of its progeny will be more
fit and so that leads to what's called
reinforcements and we can see now if we
look oh yeah we'll see in a minute what
the impact of that is trying to find
evidence for reinforcement is is been a
major task for many for two generations
although it's pretty solidly down out
what another situation that is it
besides sim pantry which I already
discussed is this pair Apache this is it
this is not in living in California this
pair of batteries quite relevant because
we have this sort of ring of mountains
and we have river systems and so
whenever you have organisms separated in
a soon of linear way for examples one a
good example then you can have
populations that are next to each other
and sometimes the the environments could
be different enough that they actually
local adaptation leads two quite
distinct populations and and so that can
lead them to the same kind of
selective zone wear jeans different
genes are moving across the hybrid zone
differently but the hybrid zone arose
not from secondary contact but from some
kind of true sort of environmental Klein
reflecting different environments almost
all of these are always tortured by that
well you know 100,000 years ago those
were actually two different populations
completely separated in its really
secondary contact I think I covered that
okay so how much time shy quit the first
lecture is over okay well I so what I I
was I'm almost there i was just going to
go to the time things of the d versus
but i think everybody wants to take a
break I can do it next I'll do it after
lunch okay so after lunch we'll spend a
little bit of time on the evidence for
the rate at which these things occur in
the difference between sim pantry and in
a low pass rate and then I want to turn
to the jeans and the genomics of hybrid
zones and hybrid in gene flow across
hybrid zones thank you